wait my I have a question how are you
guys friends you seem like the opposite
ends of the Spectrum in terms of just
like manners and character and
everything
I don't know chest muscle I know we've
always been like this no no we've always
been like this I met him at The Comedy
Store in 1998. he was working the door
yeah and then he hosted a show Andy
Sandy Shores Sandy Shore Sandy you took
a class I took a class at The Comedy
Store she took a class from Sandy Polly
Shore sister yeah and then we you know
just can we talk about the night that
you did that yeah go ahead so she then
you know he performed at because what
you do is Sandy take you take a class
from Sandy Shore rest in peace
whoever she is and I don't know where
she is you know what I mean she got
cuckoo with the you know I mean the
aliens and you know she tin foil hat and
she would go in the backyard and she
would call me and go I'm connecting with
the alien you know I mean toward the end
I I took the class before and that was
it
you seem to be in communication with a
lot of people after the thing I know and
then she would call me and go like I
need I need four thousand dollars right
and I'd be like isn't your mom Missy
Shore like what the [__] Paulie yours is
a star what do you call anyway so anyway
you took the class and then at the end
of her class she does like this big
showcase you know I mean in the main
room and one time she goes can you host
it to me and I go
okay and that's where I fought I saw
Sebastian for the very first time he was
wearing a red was it red it was a blue a
kind of like gas station shirt oh okay I
have this set on my first special as a
as a bonus feature it was the kind of
like really one of the first times I
ever did stand up it was pretty bad and
he was the host and we over time just
just from hanging out The Comedy Store
yeah became friendly then we went to the
Middle East together with Eric Griffin
yeah and that's where I was introduced
to FIFA
are you still playing no you don't play
FIFA anymore but I can still probably be
do you no I played he bought and I
thought this was so like
cool oh cool yeah because he was on Mad
TV at the time and I think I was still
in the midst of waiting tables and he
just bought like a what was it a Sega
Genesis system it was I think the Xbox
he bought an Xbox and I'm like what's
this guy doing this is unbelievable it
must be wealthy yeah and then he just
left it in the hotel room I go you're
not gonna you're not gonna take this
back to the United States he's not I'm
just like that we just use it for the
for the time we're here and I'm like
geez this game must be rolling it yeah I
remember doing that and then why do that
now like I'll go to a hotel to play
video games sometimes you bring if you
bring your Xbox or Playstation to to a
hotel they they block their television
they'll block the thing because they
they want you to use their entertainment
so I'll just buy go buy a flat screen
and you buy a flat screen on the road
instead of tipping he'll just give it to
the lady who oh yeah here's your TV
there's your 65-inch Plaza yeah a
fascinating
why yeah well I mean this is the ins and
outs of what you really don't hear about
on the road where a woman's gonna come
in and instead of receiving what are you
looking at over here
[Laughter]
she plays with stickers the whole time I
need to know that going into the thing
just be yourself I am myself yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay
so give me an example uh when you're in
the hotel room do you tell the
housekeeper this is your TV or do you
leave a note on the screen how do you do
it I'll take a um sometimes I'll take
one of those yellow post what do you
call them post them post it yeah yeah
and I'll go hola